all right John what's going on man John
uh where you from originally where'd you
grow up I'm from Los Angeles California
South Central uh P Rivera P Rivera yeah
tell me about your family growing up you
had Mom and Dad uh yeah I had a mom
that's about it um she was a she had to
work a lot so I mean I had a lot of time
to myself and
um where's your dad never met him I have
a sister but she's older she was in
Mexico though at the time when I was
when I was growing up
yeah what kind of kid were you in high
school like uh I was in the party scenes
a lot you mean I used to be in a a party
crew and all that but be before that I
was like to myself you I mean was kind
of like shy quiet and all that you I
mean and um didn't have a lot of friends
you mean but you graduated no you didn't
I used to uh ditch a lot yeah are you
working now um M I do work but
I find myself doing some other crazy
you I mean like like just basically
doing what I want to do you I mean yeah
but that takes money still yeah how do
you how do you make money oh okay well
well I guess you do kind of call it work
cuz I be
um I be
cutting cutting what um cataly
converters oh catalytic converters from
cars yeah that's crazy man that's your
hustle um yeah it is well yeah it is it
still is it's um what pay go you I mean
I've met a lot of people who had their
catalytic converters stolen from their
cars now I know who's doing it yeah so
so ban out there there a bunch of people
doing it what do you sell a catalytic
converter
for um they used to go for a
th I'm not should I be saying this like
a th2
1,200 for $1,200 yeah and we would go
and come back with 10 of
them and this guy will you guys
call them Cadillac
converters cuz you can't say catalytic
yeah well that's that's my hustle but I
went I went to jail behind that I did
some time for that so now it's like it
is my hustle but it's I try not to you
hear me cuz I'm on probation and all
that you get in trouble again yeah so
that's needed you I mean when it gets
hard when pushing comes to shove you
mean I do what I have to do so you like
to go down the Figaro Street yeah oh
that's I'm actually that's where I be at
all day every day really fig yeah it's
um it's like a little spot you I mean
that a lot of people be kicking it and
then how often hear you hiring a girl to
uh Entertain You how long how often oh
how often oh every day it could be
like three times a day four
times a day I mean that gets expensive
no yeah but um the ones that I be
knowing are
like they're like kind of low ball you I
mean you kind of get to talk to them a
little bit and then deal yeah some some
something something like that yeah
so
yeah that's a lot of girls though I mean
yeah well four
four four times a day like that or I
mean as many as I can I mean it's it's
just like I'm it's like I'm a sex addict
fullblown ever since I was like 13 you I
mean 14 really yeah I've been you know
how kids are we grow up
watch pornal and all that
and start masturbating and all that you
mean and don't stop doing that I mean
so yeah does that mean you've
probably hired every girl on fig
damn near they all they all know me
so it's
like yeah they all know me you ever get
attached to any of these girls some of
them but I try to like snap out of it
you mean can't be can't can um follow or
have feelings for this type
FAL why is that I mean cuz you mean they
do what they do you mean so I mean I'm
not going to want to share it with
nobody you mean so you want you want to
roll it yourself yeah of course yeah
well you got to take care of her in
order to do that yeah and guess
expensive take more money yeah it takes
more money
so
you ever had any uh girls hustle
you for money or the prins come in in
the picture I don't know well I did have
with this one girl she uh pepper sprayed
me one time I was in the car right so I
picked her up and I guess I wasn't I was
taking too long so she she just told me
to like to go ahead and get and do your
thing get hard you mean so I I'm doing
my thing and she just like I guess she
got mad or whatever and she just pulled
out this little pepper spray out of her
bag you mean
just pepper sprayed the out of me
that was funny I had to dry down
like all the way from 88th in fig all
the way to like 40 4th in fig
without you mean like I wasn't able to
see yeah and I still went back
the same day mean and she robbed you
yeah no well not to the to the same
female but I went to me no but but she
took your money the first time oh no no
she didn't take my money she just oh
well she did take my money cuz I paid
her you I mean but she didn't rob me you
mean yeah yeah but she she got me real
good pepper pepper spray the out of
me how old are you me I'm 39 39 have you
ever had a relationship with a girl that
is not a sex worker
um have I ever had a relationship with a
girl that's not a a worker right yeah I
have I have a baby mom oh you do
yeah yeah she didn't know about this and
you I mean and you were doing this the
whole time yeah the whole time and she
found out it was it was all bad yeah and
um why it used to take a lot from from
from the income at house you I mean cuz
I would I I would spend all my money I
would have come back yeah think it's
expensive what you're doing oh yeah I
would have come back and from work and
just not even I wouldn't even make it
home you ever get any diseases from
doing this um I think I caught a what do
they call that
um it's like
a I guess your drips yeah you got
the drips that's what they call it the
drip or the clap some like that
yeah if
you I got the C you don't use a
condom a few times I did it it was just
I don't know why
so are drugs a part of your life yeah
major part of my life what do you use uh
Crystal math Crystal math yeah is that
that that's what enhances the whole
situation I mean for me just to be out
in the street and like look for every
girl you I mean or not every girl but
just look for a girl I mean if it's
fat
skinny doesn't matter it doesn't matter
like I got to have them on and
that's just the way it makes me
feel and you're okay with this lifestyle
this these kind of relationships I'm not
okay with it
but I guess this is what I want for for
the for the moment it's like an
addiction for you right yeah oh yeah it
is an
addiction and a while back I was
addicted to porno too pornos I would
have watch a lot of porno and then my
baby mama she would she would be upset
because of that too are you addicted to
the sex or is it the crystal meth that
makes you addicted to the sex I think
it's the crystal meth that makes me yeah
cuz when I I used to be sober for a few
months and um it wasn't it was like me
and her we wouldn't have the same kind
of relationship as to the way I was when
I was high I would want to be with her
all the time mean she would always she
like say no or some should like that so
I would I'll go out and look for a
girl what do you prefer white girls
black girls Mexican girls uh Mexican
girls yeah you like the Mexican girls
yeah stti I mean I've been with a black
girl and a white girl too you I mean
so for a moment I had a like a a fantasy
on black girls you me
and I was stuck on that for a minute
like I would just get every black girl
every black girl every black girl until
I guess I just died out and is it
going to be hard for you if you ever
want to have a a normal relationship
again to to meet a female and not assume
they're going to have sex in in 10
minutes no because I I I've I've caught
myself like you I mean like since I'm
older now like I feel a little bit
different you I mean think a little bit
different but it's like my mentality is
still like young but like so I try to I
try to be more like considerate to you
mean or like to the next person if I do
if I do come across a person that I want
to be with you I
mean yeah I'm not it's not all bad like
that
but I do have feelings for other people
like you mean you ever get hassled by
the
cops on that tip no never thank
God thank God cuz then you would have to
register as a sex sex offender and all
that so oh is that right yeah I think in
our in in our like culture well not
culture but like us like we don't we is
that's a bad it's a bad um reputation on
your jacket to be like a sex offender
type
yeah you'll go without sleep now because
you're on crystal math right I've
been I've been out with no sleep for a
whole week you haven't slept for a week
right now right now wow see when I got
out I didn't sleep for a whole month
it was crazy you get out of and I
was having sex back to back and
just doing crazy you I mean
thinking crazy like I just want to
be out in the street at night
steal cars just to go and
look for tricks and I mean
tricks I mean look for you I
mean
yeah you think you'll be doing this the
rest of your life or you no I'm I'm a
barber so that's what I want to do yeah
I don't I don't want to be doing this
would you say you're happy no
emotionally this what do you go through
like I'm physically happy but not
emotionally I be like I've got a lot of
that I've went through you I mean
that I haven't dealt
with I guess for me to move on you think
not having your dad in your life played
a role in all of this I think so cuz
yeah I don't like the way I was born or
the way I was
raised my I I my attitude is kind of
like up I you I mean people like
people
see that I have like a up
attitude I mean I could see that in
them are you repeating your dad's
footsteps well I never met him so I
can't say no but you have a son or
daughter right no I have two girls yeah
how often you see them well they got
adopted so um I haven't seen them since
2014 so they're older now they're like
15 and 14 what's your biggest regret not
fighting for
them yeah not fighting for them though I
posting what's your biggest fear now
fear yeah what what are you afraid of
now being alone being alone
yes and it seems like it's going to come
down to that
point
but I mean I got potential you mean to
be a good dude you I
mean yeah would you say even though that
you're with a different girl every night
that this is a lonely life for
you um yeah cuz you don't have that
companionship or that friendship or that
you're aware that these girls are all
just yeah
it's just instant gratification for me I
mean like I'm high
and I get hot and bother or
whatever you I mean and I
just yeah want to have sex with
different
females it's kind of weird this is my
first time talking about this so if it's
sounds
weird you're doing good JN what would
you say is the most important lesson
you've learned in your
life treat people the way you want to be
treated even though I treat the way I
treat women is like
is that's that's like the best thing you
have
to learn like if you want to be treated
good you got to treat people good too
yeah John thank you so much for sharing
your story all right bro I wish you lots
of luck out there thank you thanks
man